kliniken in geldnot in der korona
pandemie könnten gehälter bald nicht
mehr gezahlt werden warnt die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft konzerte und
flugreisen bald nur für geimpfte nein
sagt die koalition und prüft ein verbot
möglicher privilegien und so springt ein
sieger karl geiger gewinnt den auftrag
der vierschanzentournee in oberstdorf
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert lehmann für den sport ein
wunder noch vor mir
seit fast zwei wochen ist das land im
corona shutdown
doch ob er wirkt und aber reicht ist
offen
in einer woche wollen bund und länder
entscheiden ob die beschränkungen über
den zehnten januar hinaus verlängert
werden
die frage ist auf welcher datengrundlage
sie das tun
aktuell meldet das robert-koch-institut
12 1892 neue infektionen innerhalb von
24 stunden
852 menschen sind in verbindung mit coop
19 gestorben
allerdings sind diese zahlen nicht nur
wegen der feiertage unvollständig david
sauer limit wird in vielen kliniken
gearbeitet und weiter sterben viele
menschen an cupid dabei sinken die
gemeldeten infektionszahlen seit den
weihnachtsfeiertagen deutlich eigentlich
grund zum aufatmen die daten sind aber
kaum belastbar weil unvollständig wir
hatten schon noch vor den
weihnachtsfeiertagen einige fälle
gemeldet bekommen aber jetzt auch war ja
die labors in den zwei tagen nicht
gearbeitet haben
doch deutlich weniger fallzahlen denn an
feiertagen und wochenenden gehen
deutlich weniger menschen zu ärzten es
wird weniger getestet und nicht alle
gesundheitsämter übermitteln täglich
daten
das problem ist nicht neu seit beginn
der pandemie verspricht die politik hier
abhilfe
die gesundheitsämter mit qualifiziertem
fachpersonal weiter auszustatten und
ehrlicher weise ein stück besser zu
bezahlen
als sein vorgänger der fall war sieben
monate später hat sich wenig geändert
in der partie hat das zwar hilfskräfte
gegeben die jetzt unterstützen das
reicht aber nicht aus wir brauchen
dringend mehr personal in den
gesundheitsämtern und müssen die
digitalisierung voranbringen damit es
verlässliche belastbare zahlen gibt
davon hängt viel ab kontakt
beschränkungen geschlossene gastronomie
und der einzelhandel
es ist schon eine strategie dass wir
natürlich immer angepasst an die zahlen
entscheiden wollen auch was wir zulassen
können ich gehe fest davon aus dass wir
weiterhin mit einschränkungen leben
müssen ob weihnachten einen infektions
treiber war wies gewinn in den usa lässt
sich noch nicht sagen
heute in einer woche werden die
ministerpräsidenten und die
bundeskanzlerin über ihr vorgehen
beraten viele fragezeichen also um die
aktuellen corona zahlen auf zdf heute
und in unserer app zeigen wir beispiele
dafür
welche lücken es gerade in der
datenerfassung gibt die kliniken
schlagen alarm ein erheblicher teil ihre
pflegekräfte könnte in den nächsten
wochen ausfallen wegen der andauernden
überlastung durch corona dazu mangelt es
an geld bald könnten viele kliniken
nicht mal mehr gehälter bezahlen heißt
es von der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft der
gesundheitsminister verspricht hilfe bot
spiekermann corona treibt kliniken in
einem täglichen grenzbereich angesichts
der immer noch hohen infektionszahlen
werden intensivbetten und personal knapp
die lage auf der intensivstation ist
nach wie vor wirklich sehr angespannt
allein hier in der städteregion aachen
wo ich mich befinde haben wir aktuell
nur sieben prozent freie betten auch in
köln unter zehn prozent freie
intensivbetten und in anderen regionen
sieht das ähnlich aus dazu kommen
finanzielle engpässe
zwei drittel aller klinikbetreiber
rechnen laut deutscher
krankenhausgesellschaft mit verlusten im
jahr 2020
der grund viele operationen werden seit
monaten verschoben
all das führt dazu dass die
krankenhäuser enorme erlösausfälle haben
und diese erlösausfälle müssen durch
liquiditätshilfen ausgeglichen werden
weil wir ansonsten unsere kosten und
dazu gehören eben auch löhne und
gehälter nicht mehr bedienen können
schon im ersten quartal 2021 könnte es
ging
besonders corona belastete kliniken
bekommen zwar ausgleichszahlungen davon
profitieren aber nur 25 prozent aller
krankenhäuser
der hilferuf der kliniken ist adressiert
an den bundesgesundheitsminister jens
spahn reagierte heute mit einer gehälter
garantie wir wollen und werden die
liquidität der krankenhäuser in der
krise sichern
darauf können sich die beschäftigten
verlassen das krankenhaus system unter
druck bereits existierende milliarden
rettungsschirme reichen offenbar nicht
aus
schon beim bund länder treffen am 5
januar könnte die
krankenhausfinanzierung auf der
tagesordnung stehen
seit dem wochenende wird in deutschland
gegen korona geimpft bis einschließlich
gestern haben knapp 42.000 menschen ihre
erste dosis bekommen es wird also noch
viele monate dauern bis ein
ausreichender impfschutz aufgebaut ist
zudem sind möglicherweise auch geimpfte
noch ansteckend trotzdem wird schon
diskutiert ob es für sie sonderrechte
geben darf russlands g berichtet die
australische fluggesellschaft quantas
denkt darüber nach auf bestimmten
strecken nur noch geimpfte antwort zu
lassen
nun überlegt auch die lufthansa bei
langstreckenflügen entweder schnell test
oder impfung
seit sonntag wird erst geimpft und schon
entbrennt eine diskussion um
sonderrechte für geimpfte wir wollen
keine spaltung unserer gesellschaft und
zumindest zu dem zeitpunkt wo noch nicht
einmal alle bürgerinnen und bürger die
chance haben sich impfen lassen zu
können und wenn jetzt noch nicht einmal
feststeht ob die ängste nicht doch
ansteckend sein könnten
so lange darf es keine sonderrechte für
geimpfte personen gehen die vorsitzende
des ethikrates man zu augenmaß und
geduld und fordert eine
gesellschaftliche debatte
es ist klug damit sehr bald zu beginn
man muss nur einfach deutlich
unterstreichen dass man nicht für jetzt
nachdenkt also für diese zeit der
knappheit und der priorisierung sondern
dass man vor baut für eine phase in der
wir für alle impfungen anbieten können
die das auch wollen und dann sollte man
sich differenziert anschauen
in welchen bereichen könnte so etwas
möglich und auch unproblematisch sein
und wo bräuchte man gegebenenfalls eine
regulierung die koalition prüft bereits
wie man nicht geimpfte vor
diskriminierung schützen kann denn im
privaten bereich gebe es eine
regelungslücke kneipen restaurants oder
kinos haben das hausrecht und wollen
schnellstmöglich wieder öffnen
doch eine impfpflicht durch die
hintertür nicht die koalition ab wir
haben auf der einen seite den staat der
nicht diskriminieren darf und wir haben
auf der anderen seite die
privatwirtschaft mit vertragsfreiheit
und das muss man zusammenbringen
auch verbraucherschützer fordern
sicherheit gegen diskriminierung eine
debatte die mit jeder weiteren impfung
an fahrt gewinnt etwas wie normalität
wiederherstellen dazu könnten auch
schnelltests beitragen einen angeblich
besonders guten präsentieren nun
entwickler in bayern sie sagen ihr
verfahren sei schneller und
unkomplizierter als gängige pcr tests
und zudem genauer als antigen schnittes
patricia schäfer hat mir diese kästchen
bergen neue hoffnung im kampf gegen
korona so sicher wie ein normaler pcr
test aber viel schneller liefern die
testergebnisse in nur 40 minuten können
acht rachenabstriche ausgewertet werden
in dem gerät in der größe nach
haushaltslage
entwickelt hat das verfahren ein junges
forscherteam aus bayern in der eigenen
biotech-firma bei unserem pcr verfahren
brauchen wir nicht gesamte flüssigkeit
zu erwerben sondern nur ein ganz ganz
kleinen bruchteil
das können wir sehr viel schneller
machen das kann man mit weniger energie
machen und das kann man mit einem sehr
kleinen kompakten gerät machen
während andere pcr verfahren die gesamte
flüssigkeit 40 mal auf heizung abkühlen
müssen
bringen wir die wärme ganz punktuell
dorthin wo das erbgut des virus es sich
befindet
die mobile teststation kann überall
aufgebaut werden
labor kraft entnimmt und bearbeitet die
proben in der testreihe für die
zulassung zeigten sich hervorragende
ergebnisse beim erkennen des virus das
müsse nun von unabhängigen labors
überprüft werden sagt biologin ulrike
protzer doch schon jetzt sieht sie große
vorteile
es gibt schon eine reihe solcher
sogenannter point of care schnell teste
die auch pcr basiert sind nur die sind
sehr begrenzt in ihrer verfügbarkeit die
sind sehr teuer und man bekommt einfach
die test materialien nicht
das heißt jetzt ein test hier aus
deutschland zu haben wo wir dann auch
primär den zugriff haben und nicht auf
den goodwill der amerikaner angewiesen
sind wäre schon ein riesenvorteil zum
einsatz kommen die kompakten pcr
schnelltests schon im januar in
bayerischen kliniken aber auch für
mitarbeiter von schlachthöfen und an
flughäfen in zwei tagen endet eine der
maßnahmen die laut finanzminister scholz
in der korona pandemie einem wumms
bringen sollte die senkung der
mehrwertsteuer
der staat wollte das alles etwas
billiger wird zeitlich begrenzt damit
kunden größere anschaffungen jetzt
machen und nicht verschieben
die frage ist hat das was gebracht kaum
sagen verbraucherschützer und handel
stefan schlösser mit der bilanz die
mehrwertsteuersenkung sollte wieder mehr
kunden in die geschäfte locken und den
konsum ankurbeln aus sicht von jochen
ruß hat das aber nicht funktioniert er
besitzt ein modehaus und ist präsident
des hessischen handelsverbands wenn wir
nach sechs monaten zurück schauen müssen
wir sagen das ganze war eine luftnummer
gewesen ja wir haben uns da einen
riesenaufwand in die einzelnen betriebe
reingeholt der staat hat eine menge geld
in die hand genommen und letzten endes
der große effekt ist ausgeblieben
wahrscheinlich gab es überhaupt keinen
effekt oder ganz marginal nach angaben
der deutschen bundesbank wurde die
senkung der mehrwertsteuer nur zu rund
60 prozent an die verbraucher
weitergegeben
vor allem bei den lebensmitteln in den
supermärkten weniger bei
dienstleistungen wie friseur oder
restaurantbesuchen das hat man schon
gemerkt dass ich was gesenkt hat hier
und da wenn man viel einkaufen muss
schon dadurch dass der kurzarbeit
angesagt das muss man natürlich auch
eigene tasche bisschen sparen und gucken
daher größere einkäufe natürlich nicht
ich habe mir dann nichts neues an weil
drei prozent rechnen dass auch mal aus
was das ist genau drei euro bei einem
einkauf von 100 euro netto bei 1000 euro
sind es dann 30 wer mehr hat mehr kauft
sich große anschaffungen leisten kann
der konnte auch mehr sparen es wäre
wesentlich besser gewesen durch eine
senkung der stromkosten alle menschen
vor allem geringverdiener zu erreichen
und der kinderbonus war ebenfalls eine
genaue entlastung für familien darin
wäre das geld wesentlich besser
investiert gewesen und für die geschäfte
und unternehmen die geschlossen haben
überhaupt keinen umsatz machen bringt
die mehrwertsteuersenkung ohnehin nichts
ein blick nach südafrika
dort gilt seit mitternacht ein neuer
lockdown mit ausgangssperren
alkoholverbot und strenger masken
pflicht mehr als eine million menschen
sind dort inzwischen mit dem virus
infiziert die zahl steigt seit ende
november wieder deutlich grund ist
offenbar eine ansteckende variante des
corona virus wer ohne maske erwischt
wird dem drohen bis zu einem halben jahr
freiheitsstrafe weltweit zahlen viele
journalistinnen und journalisten mit
ihrem leben für eine unabhängige
berichterstattung mindestens 50 wurden
in diesem jahr getötet so die
organisation reporter ohne grenzen die
meisten opfer seien gezielt ermordet
worden wegen kritischer berichte etwa
über korruption mafia oder
umweltzerstörung mexiko sei erneut das
gefährlichste land für journalisten ein
schweres erdbeben hat am mittag kroatien
getroffen es hatte die stärke von 6,4
das epizentrum lag etwa 50 kilometer
südöstlich der hauptstadt zagreb in der
nähe der kleinstadt petrini mindestens
sechs menschen kamen ums leben darunter
ein zwölfjähriges mädchen
rettungsmannschaften suchen unter den
trümmern nach verschütteten mindestens
20 menschen wurden verletzt
im benachbarten slowenien schalteten die
behörden aus sicherheitsgründen ein
atomkraftwerk ab sie müssen bei heftigen
schnee und minusgraden draußen überleben
rund 2000 flüchtlinge rund um ein
abgebranntes zeltlager in bosnien
herzegowina mit becken versuchen sie
gegen die kälte zu schützen ihre
situation in lima nahe der stadt biel
hat ist geprägt von hunger armut und nun
erstmals auch ein wenig hoffnung britta
hilpert berichtet für hunderte
flüchtlinge sind diese busse ein
lichtblick
sie sollen sie wegbringen aus dem camp
lieber im bosnischen bucht ein
unmenschliches flüchtlingslager für rund
2000 menschen kaum
lebensmittelversorgung ohne strom wasser
heizung nur vor keine sie kein geld
riesenproblem
ich bin hungrig es gibt nur einmal am
tag was zu essen
kurz vor weihnachten brannte das lager
lipa internationale hilfsorganisationen
wollten es schließen da die versorgung
hier im winter unmöglich sein zumal ihm
nein die hat eine lehre fabrikhalle
steht bereit für die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen
es ist eine politische blockade aufheben
2000 menschen schlafen
draußen im kreisel und hier ist ein
zentrum warm und voll ausgestattet von
der eu und es wird nicht genutzt
die stadt biel hat weigert sich es zu
öffnen
man habe schon genug getan muss wo im
gremium erst muss man sich um unsere
bürger kümmern dann um flüchtlinge dass
sie durch den winter kommen
das darf nicht auf unserem rücken
ausgetragen werden rund 2000 flüchtlinge
wurden über bi hat einen weg in die eu
finden viele kempten nun wild die
nächste kältewelle könnte für sie fatale
ihren ein teil von ihnen wird heute in
eine leere kaserne bei sarajevo gebracht
doch für hunderte weitere flüchtlinge
ist noch keine lösung in sicht
jetzt noch ein abschied er gilt als
einer der grössten modeschöpfer
überhaupt einer der reichsten war er
allemal
der kader ist mit 98 jahren gestorben
als einer der ersten hat er mode für die
masse entworfen und wie kein anderer
seinen namen weltweit vermarktet susanne
freitag
er hat nie aufgehört sich selbst neu zu
erfinden war schon über 90 als er sein
museum in paris eröffnet seine eltern
waren bauern in italien und der kleine
pietro germi wieso ist ein geburtsname
hatte schon ganz früh den 13
schon mit acht jahren war ich erstaunt
wenn ich modemagazin sah wie anders
diese models aussahen
mode ist ja immer einen schritt weiter
1946 begann seine karriere bei bio aber
schon 1950 machte er seine eigene mode
er erfand das pret a porter eine echte
revolution wie alles was er anfasst die
beatles trugen die ersten kragenlosen
sakkos seine erfindet er war der erste
designer der in moskau seine kreationen
zeigen durfte obwohl es den eisernen
vorhang noch gehabt und der erste der in
china eine modenschau machte und auch
das war neun er vermarktete sich selbst
klar da das stand auf bach auf
bettwäsche auf lampen auf feinkost er
hatte die lizenz für über 800 produkte
folge kreatur und geschäftsmann fest ins
hohe alter
natürlich bin ich im rentenalter sagte
er zuletzt
aber ich möchte gerne
qaradawi futurist und trotzdem zeitlos
seine lieblings kleider sind die für das
leben das es noch nicht gibt kleider für
die welt von morgen
tja jetzt sports immer zu dir und zum
auftakt der vierschanzentournee
ja und da hat ein oberstdorfer gewonnen
in oberstdorf skiflug weltmeister karl
geiger ein turbulenter auftakt dafür
hatte das polnische team gesorgt gestern
bei der quali wegen eines kroner falls
nicht dabei heute aber alle tests
negativ deshalb doch statt erlaubnis ja
und so wurde es richtig richtig spannend
auf der schattenbergschanze ein
nervenstarker karl geiger sorgt für den
ersten tournee auftakt sieg eines dsv
springer es seit fünf jahren ist der
erste durchgang aber zwei gute sprünge
und ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen
soll wenn wir jetzt nur zuschauer werden
dann wäre es perfekt bei starkem
rückenwind im ersten durchgang schafft
ist markus eisenbichler als
fünfundzwanzigster gerade noch in die
zweite runde als einer von nur drei
deutschen am besten klarkommt karl
geiger mit diesem satz auf 127 meter
die führung bei kurzzeitig verlängertem
anlauf besser macht es eisenbichler im
zweiten 142 meter weiteste sprung des
tages am ende platz fünf
polens khamis doch unbeeindruckt vom
zeitweisen ausschluss seines teams
gestern liegt in führung bis karl geiger
auch im zweiten durchgang sein oder
kantate zeigt 136 eineinhalb meter karl
geiger reist mit knapp drei punkten
vorsprung aufs doch zum neujahrsspringen
us ski rennläufer ryan cochrane siegl
hat beim weltcup rennen im italienischen
bormio den super g gewonnen
der 28 jahre alte sohn der
slalom-olympiasiegerin von unserer 72
barbara n cochrane landete souverän auf
platz eins vor dem österreicher vincent
kriechmayr und dem norweger arien suisse
sa estate bester starter des deutschen
skiverbandes bei romed baumann mit einem
starken siebten platz
ja jetzt ist offiziell paris st-germain
trennt sich von trainer thomas tuchel
der hatte den verein zweimal zu
französischen fußball-meisterschaft
geführt pc ist zurzeit tabellendritter
und auch beim abstiegsbedrohten
bundesligisten mainz 05 dreht sich das
personalkarussel der neue sportvorstand
christian heidel und der neue
sportdirektor martin schmitt wir haben
sich heute der presse vorgestellt
wo ist die trennung von trainer jan
moritz lichte bekannt gegeben sein
nachfolger soll nach dem spiel gegen die
bayern am sonntag bekanntgegeben werden
dort heißt es der kandidat ist übrigens
der mainzer ex profi bo svensson mainzer
sind treue sehen wie man sieht
dankeschön auf vieles müssen wir in
diesem jahr verzichten aber nicht auf
die sternsingerinnen und sternsinger
rund 300.000 wollen mitmachen manche
ziehen wie gewohnt von haus zu hause
wenn auch mit mundschutz
aber das besondere diesmal den segen
gibt es auch ein video oder als brief
unser stern strahlt heller denn je das
ist die botschaft
35 jahre lang hat unser meteorologe
gunther tiersch ihr das wetter bestimmt
heute verabschiedet wer sich vom
bildschirm und das auch noch mit trüben
aussichten
wir danken ihm jedenfalls sehr und
wünschen ihm alles gute im heute-journal
freut sich marietta slomka auf sie wir
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und sind machen wieder dabei sind
[Musik]
und damit dem zuschauer im westen wird
er nass im osten eher ein bisschen
sonnig der winter ist ja gezählt bei uns
findet er so in den mittelgebirgen stadt
und die eisige kälte ist ja weit
entfernt im norden von russland dann
aber schnell mit minus 20 grad ganz
anders am östlichen mittelmeer da ist es
eher frühlingshaft teilweise erleben wir
temperaturen von knapp 20 grad und bei
uns gibt es natürlich wieder leichten
frost in den letzten nächten allerdings
im norden und im westen bleibt es
frostfrei da ist es stark bewölkt in
dieser nacht immer wieder gibt es im
westen und in den mittelgebirgen dort
schnee und schneeregen schauer ansonsten
eben leichter regen an den küsten und
das ändert sich auch morgen nicht auch
dort haben wir dann immer wieder im
westen mit schnee und schneeregen zu tun
schnee vor allen dingen den
mittelgebirgen oberhalb von 500 metern
dagegen an den küsten regnet leicht oder
es gibt ein bisschen schnee regen nach
osten und süden hin kommt aber die sonne
raus und die temperaturen ändern sich
dabei kaum
es sind wieder so zwischen 1 und 6 grad
ja und in den nächsten tagen zum
jahreswechsel wird es wohl eher im
westen nass oder auch ein bisschen weiß
im neuen jahr kann dann mehr und mehr
die sonne scheint ja liebe zuschauer das
war meine letzte sendung nach den heute
-nachrichten nach 35 jahren ist jetzt
schluss ich möchte mich herzlich bei
ihnen für das interesse an den
wetterberichten bedanken wünsche ihnen
eine angenehme zeit und machen sie es
gut